اليوم يعني استمعنا الى هذه القصه وكل
الناس عارفه طب شو الصوره القانونيه
المخرج القانوني لهكذا قضيه من يحاسب وعلى
من تقع المسؤوليه بالاساس
اولا قبل مبدا حديثي يعني اتمنى الشفاء
العاجل للسيد المصاب بساعتك بسبب الواقع
ديت وربنا ان شاء الله يتم عليه بالشفاء
وان شاء الله يرجع لبيته سالم وغانم
بمناسبه الشهور الكريمه الشهر الكريم اللي
احنا داخلين عليه
اولا سعادتك احب بس قد تعريف سعادتك عن
الكلاب البيتبول قبل ما اخش في الناحيه
القانونيه الكلاب البيتبول دي سعادتك من
الانواع الشرسه جدا هي والكلاب الروت
فايلر وفي 18 نوع من الكلاب دي شرسه جدا
جدا
لدرجه ان دوله زي كندا بتحذر دخول هذه
الكلاب
الى كندا ليه لان هي كلاب شرسه جدا
بطبيعتها على سبيل المثال الكلب البيتبول
صاحب الواقعه معلومه لحضراتكم هو في قوه
ربع اسد اقول ثاني هو في قوه ربع اسد يعني
اربع كلاب من البيتبول يمثلوا اسد كامل
فده قوي جدا وشرس جدا
بالاضافه ان طبعا ربنا خلقه من نوع
المهاجم والشرس
فاداله فك ليس فك مستوي زي اسنان البشر لا
او الفك ما بيبقاش مظبوط كده للسنان فوق
بعضيها بالمنظر ده لا الفك في تجويفات
يعني ساعتك السنان لما بيقفل بيدخل جوه
بعضيها بالمنظر دوت بيدخل جوه بعديها
بالمنظر ده من نوعيه التماسيح والقروش
بمعنى ادق ان العضه بتاعته سعادتك ممكن
تجيب قطن في العظم وتهدته طبعا في جميع
الانسجه والاورده فهو طبيعته شرس من نوعيه
مثلا النمور والاسود والكلام ده كله فطبعا
دي محظور سعادتك دخولها مثلا دوله زي كندا
بتحذر دخولها تماما
للاسف الشديد في القانون المصري اه للاسف
الشديد بقى في القانون المصري ندخل فيها
القانون المصري ينظم كل حاجه طبعا لكن
للاسف الشديد ما كانش لسه الطفره دي دخلت
علينا في مصر اللي هي طفره تربيه الكلاب
بالنسبه حضرتك للناس الاغنياء بالذات لان
طبعا تكلفه تربيه الكلب في مصر مكلفه
مكلفه جدا يعني عشان يارب الكلب زي زي
الكلاب ليس محظور امتلاكه في مصر اليوم
اتحدث عن ضحيه دخل مرحله الغيبوبه باصابات
بالغه وصاحب الكلب تم حبسه على ذمه
التحقيق ما العقوبات المنتظره في هذه
الحاله قانونيا ماذا سيحصل
هو قانونا سعادتك هنقول سعادتك اذا
اتكلمنا عن الماده 377 فقره اتنين ده
سعادتك في قانون العقوبات بيقول لك ايه
الماده دي بتقول ايه ان سعادتك غرامه 100
جنيه فقط لا غير غرامه 100 جنيه في حاله
ان واحد يكون مسؤول عن حيوان ولم يحسن
السيطره عليه يعني مثلا على سبيل المثال
وقع زي اللي احنا فيها او مثلا حصان ماشي
في الشارع رفس واحد فاموته او احدث به
اصابه دي القانون المصري يساعد لك الماده
377 فقره اتنين بتقول غرامها 100 جنيه
ولكن القوانين المدني القانون المدني
بيقول لك يلزم سعادتك التعويض في الماده
176 من القانون المدني بيقول لك المسؤوليه
عن عن عمل الغير المسؤوله عن
المسؤول عن استعمال الاشياء فحارس الحيوان
هو مسؤول عنه اذا احدث اصابه بالغير فهو
ملزم بتعويض المجني عليه لكن طبعا بعد
انتشار هذه الظاهره من سد الثغرات
القانونيه
حصل تشريع في مجلس الشعب والزم وطبعا طبقا
لقانون البيئه لقانون اربعه لسنه 94 ان هو
يعمل سعادتك يعمل ايه بقى
يجرا هذه الوقعات والزم فيها سعادتك الحبس
من سنتين لخمس سنوات للمسؤول عن الحيوان
الذي احدث ضرار من غير يعني اذا افترضنا
اذا افترضنا الكلب لو هاجم المجني عليه من
رقبته كان طبعا هيموته هيقتله فكل ما في
الامر القولون المصري اقام بتشريع نص خاص
بهذه الواقعه والزم فيها الحبس من سنتين
لخمس سنوات